Programmers often take many
responsibilities within a team.
Sometimes programmers wear many hats and
are able to branch out
of their specific roles.
And other times they work
with other programmers
with more specialized skills.
Front-end programmers have
a unique role on teams.
They connect with other programmers
to collaborate on projects.
Remember, every team and
company will function differently.
Generally, front-end programmers link
with UX UI designers to translate design
mock-ups into full functioning websites
using HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
They also connect with
back-end developers
to think through how client data
will be stored, used and displayed.
They also may interact with product
managers about the overall vision and
requirements for the final product.
Front-end programmers are just one piece
of the puzzle when it comes to creating
web application.
In the next lesson,
we'll learn about back-end programmers.